I would start this with a gag about how there’s
nothing worth saying about Street Fighter:
The Legend of Chun Li, but I’m gonna be
talking for, like, twenty minutes straight,
so here we go,
Street Fighter: the Legend of Chun Li, a massive
failure of intent.
[Title Theme]
Street Fighter: the Legend of Chun Li is a
very odd film.
It feels like an honest attempt at taking
the video game adaptation and elevating it
to the same level of respect as literary adaptations,
and does so by mimicking…
The Transformers.
You said cars pick their drivers.
Sometimes they pick a driver with a cheap-ass
father, out the car.
Now, this isn’t to say that the literary
adaptation is inherently high class, there
are definitely greater and lesser adaptations
out there
On one hand you have adaptations like Annihilation
that, while not strictly faithful to the original
text capture the spirit of the novel in a
way that takes advantage of the change in
medium, and on the other hand you have stuff
like Earthsea.
Did you see those red marking on the side
of its head?
Yes, very attractive.
I've read about a dragon once with markings
like those.
Fascinating, you can tell me by the fire one
night.
Wait a minute. Red markings?
Like the dragon that ravaged Tavnor?
That's the one, do you remember it's true
name?
The one to bind it?
The one to subdue it to your will so you can
ask it any three questions you desire?
Yes!
but that specific spread in quality, and the
sheer volume of adaptations that have been
made, means that a movie based on a book tends
to get a pretty fair shake critically.
The presuppositions created by the phrase
“based on the best selling novel” are
broadly neutral, trending toward positive.
The same cannot be said for the phrase “based
on the hit video game.”
The pursuit of the “respectable” video
game movie has remained elusive, but boy are
studios still trying.
Tomb Raider and Assassin’s Creed would be
the most recent failed attempts at securing
some prestige, but let’s roll back a decade.
It’s 2009.
The Playstation 3 and XBox 360 are hits, and
high definition gaming is no longer next gen,
it’s the standard.
Blockbuster video games are investing more
and more in narrative.
Genres that would have previously done little
more than pointed the player in a direction
and just said “yeah, uh, shoot the dudes
in red” are expected to have a campaign
laden with pathos, melodrama, full voice acting,
and mocapped facial animation.
Simultaneously so-called nerd culture has
surged into the mainstream with the better
part of the decade being dominated by huge
geek franchises such as Harry Potter, the
Lord of the Rings, Star Wars, and Transformers
dominating the box office and, to a large
degree, the cultural zeitgeist itself.
In 2009 Capcom tried to capitalize on this
apparent respectability by turning Street
Fighter into an arty crime drama.
By copying The Transformers.
It did not work.
I love this job
While the dramatic qualities of Michael Bay’s
2007 Transformers have been the subject of
endless ridicule and criticism, the spectacle
still resonated with audiences, and those
profits definitely resonated with investors.
From aspect ratio to colour palette to story
structure, everything about Legend of Chun Li
is the budget-friendly version.
Same aspect ratio, but using spherical lenses
instead of expensive, troublesome anamorphic lenses.
Same colour palette, but in broad, washed
tones instead of an expensive frame-by-frame
colour grade.
Same plot structure with a superfluous Troopcop
b-plot that only collides with the a-plot
at the very end.
It’s actually kind of unsettling the degree
to which Legend of Chun Li is clearly cribbing
from Michael Bay’s notes, all part of an
attempt at coding itself as a “real movie”.
It even aspires to a similar weight and intensity.
Not just action, but capital D Drama, which
brings us to the other primary influence,
Ang Lee’s Crouching Tiger.
On some level this project started as Crouching
Tiger, they wanted Legend of Chun Li to be
a martial arts action movie that was, at its
core, a character driven drama, much like
Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon.
That's not a bad goal, all told, and a character
like Chun Li isn't a bad choice if that's
the story you want to tell.
Within the Street Fighter universe Chun Li
is easily one of the more accessible characters.
She's an attractive martial artist who works
for Interpol, she's out to avenge her father's
death, and... that's about it.
Unlike a lot of the other characters from
the games you don't have to exposit a deep
mythology, explain magic powers, or introduce
dozens of other core characters in order to
tell her basic story.
It is a straightforward origins and revenge
plot, which frees you up to really focus on,
well, character and story.
A good cue to the dramatic intent of the film
is in the specifics of the editing.
The movie starts with a glory shot of the
Golden Gate bridge which pans over to kid
Chun Li playing piano and her father watching
proudly while adult Chun Li narrates over
top ruminating on her childhood dream of being
a concert pianist.
This moment lasts almost a minute and has
only two edits for a very quick insert.
From there the film cuts into a much faster
paced sequence of aerial shots of Hong Kong,
and the music changes from relaxed piano to
tense electro rock.
Both the editor and cinematographer are working
to bring us into Chun Li's emotional space,
they want us to share her viewpoint and understand
the contrast in her life, the peace and serenity
of her early years in San Francisco versus
the uncertainty and chaos of Hong Kong.
This is solid fundamental film making.
So what’s the problem?
[Laughs] oh boy is the script terrible.
That’s not the only problem, but if we were
to point to a singular core issue that's what
went wrong with Crouching Pianist Hidden Street
Fighter: the script sucks.
The performances leave a lot to be desired,
but it’s hard to give a powerful performance
when the script consists of gems like this:
my father was an important business man
Your father was a very well connected business
man.
Kreuk sounds like she's reading a bedtime
story to a three year old.
Which, yeah, sure, a great way to really elevate
your video game movie is to condescend to
the audience like they’re actual children,
sure, yeah.
With my mother gone, the path in front of
me was empty.
I couldn't help feeling like I was being led
somewhere new.
I’m actually willing to bet that this voice
over, like many a terrible narrator past,
was a late addition once they realized the
plot was not particularly compelling on its
own merits and audiences were having trouble
following the setup because it’s boring.
However Kreuk’s condescending narration
is not the least of the script's problems.
For some brevity, let's just make it into
a list of major flaws, though I'm not going
to be able to get to all of these.
1 - Terrible dialogue
2 - Villain with unclear goals and motivations
3 - Poorly explained stakes
4 - Multiple extraneous characters with dead
end plotlines
5 - Main character learns nothing worthwhile
and does not change
6 - Changes are made to the source material
that actively makes the story worse
7 - Inconsistent moral core in a movie about
doing the right thing
And that is the bottom line that we’re going
to dig into here: this movie sucks because
the script is terrible.
Let’s talk about that plot, shall we?
As a young child Chun Li wants to be a concert
pianist.
Her family moves to Hong Kong.
She is taught Wushu by her father.
However at a young age her father is kidnapped
by Bison, played here by Neal McDonough doing
his best to try and set himself apart from
Raul Julia’s sublime performance of the
character by acting the character with a lilting
Irish brogue.
Chun Li grows up and does become a concert
pianist.
After a performance one night she receives
an ancient scroll as a gift from an unknown
person.
On her way home she sees a man with a spider
web tattoo on his hand get mugged in the subway,
and she calls for help, but no one comes and
then the scene just ends.
This is the kind of moment that isn’t going
to stand out on the first viewing, because
you mentally assume they’re going to fill
it in down the line, but they don’t.
I am, despite multiple viewings, hard pressed
to explain the point or purpose of this mugging
scene.
Moving on Chun Li’s mom dies of cancer.
Bison has his business partners killed for
no discernible reason.
Bison menaces Chun Li’s father who he has
stashed away in a basement somewhere doing
something.
After her mother’s funeral Chun Li gets
her scroll read and the woman tells her she
needs to find a man named Gen, who’s the
guy with the spider web tattoo, and then I
guess Chun Li becomes homeless in Thailand
because that’s her plan to find Gen?
This isn't well explained at all, a lot changes
very quickly, and none of her friends or family
seem concerned that she's quitting her job
and moving to Bangkok on a whim shortly following
the death of her mother without making any
prior arrangements for housing, finances,
or contact.
We'll come back to this plot point later.
Bison acts menacing while talking about real
estate.
Chun Li fights off six guys while starving
and sleep deprived, then collapses after murdering
a man by dropping a shelving unit full of
power tools onto him.
She's picked up by Gen who takes her back
to his place and trains her to make fireballs
in an extended training montage and he tells
Chun Li that Bison is the person who kidnapped
her father, and so Chun Li starts spying on
Bison’s team.
Actually, as a part of this he explains that
he used to be part of Shadaloo, Bison's organization,
but he grew a conscience so he started the
Order of the Web to try and repair the damage
that he had done as a criminal, but he’s
only, like, fifty, which would mean these
ancient scrolls are younger than a New Kids
on the Block poster.
So the next 20 minutes or so are largely concerned
with Bison’s real estate conspiracy.
He is, I guess, extorting the city of Bankok
into selling him the riverside slums so that
he can kick out all the residents, bulldoze
the neighbourhood, and build a series of luxury
condos, but I’m not sure why he needs to
do all this extorting because this sounds
like exactly the kind of garbage move cities
are already more than willing to do.
Also there’s a MacGuffin called the White
Rose that Bison is trying to smuggle into
the city.
This sub plot leads to Chun Li following Bison’s
henchwoman Cantana into a nightclub where
we’re going to put the movie on pause and
talk for a second about gaze.
I have talked in the past about the Kuleshov
effect, the principle of Montage, and the
psychological mechanisms through which editing
creates meaning.
Now, gaze describes the act of looking.
In a film context we are principally concerned
with the gaze of the camera, meaning what
the camera chooses to look at and how it chooses
to look at it, and yes this involves anthropomorphizing
the movie.
No better are the ideas of gaze and montage
demonstrated than when a film chooses to use
its gaze to express the gaze of a character
within the film, which is itself a situation
manufactured to justify gazing.
So, Chun Li’s plan to get information out
of Cantana is to seduce her, a plan to which
Cantana is potentially receptive because she’s
attracted to women, a detail that is communicated
to us the audience via the camera following
her gaze, and gazing on the women in the dance
club.
This isn’t necessarily condemnation, but
I think it’s useful and instructive to actually
break down the why and how of this information
exchange, how is it that we, as an audience,
come to understand that Cantana is attracted
to women purely via the use of juxtaposed
images.
Being aware of these kinds of mechanisms makes
us more alert as film viewers, more conscious
of the ways in which a film is steering our
attention and our emotions, and in turn making
us better equipped to vocalize the messages
that media is presenting us with, in this
case the way that the film has chosen to justify
staring at women’s asses by using a female
character as the agent of that staring.
Anyway, this subplot ends with Chun Li fighting
Cantana in the bathroom, and as she’s escaping
from the nightclub she shoots a man in the
chest at point blank range.
So, yeh, he’s dead.
In a scene that is up there in the realms
of “where did they think they were going
with this?”
Bison is using Cantana’s dead body as a
punching bag because she’d already said
too much.
Alright, strap in for a second, ‘cus this
is where things really jump off the rails.
Like, the punching bag scene is definitely
something, Gen fills in Bison’s whole back
story.
So, in his youth as the orphan of some Irish
missionaries who died in Thailand he used
to just steal fish but crossfade time jump
to much later in life when he’s I guess
no longer homeless he takes his very pregnant
new wife to a cave and kills her by ripping
their baby out through her belly in order
to put all his goodness into the baby so that
he wouldn't have a conscience and would only
be pure evil.
We'll come back to this one too.
Evil guys attack the secret hide out in the
stupidest way possible.
They send in ninjas to fight hand to hand
when they have a rocket launcher in the car.
Both parts of that are stupid, but it does
give us the best line in the film.
I'll do it myself
In the explosion Gen dies, then Bison hires
Vega to kill Chun Li then Vega promptly gets
his ass kicked.
Now, this next scene, Chun Li physically assaults
a civilian for not giving up private shipping
manifests and gets some more information about
the White Rose, but for me the scene is more
instructive because of the sound.
I haven’t pointed this out up until now,
but the dialogue in the film has overwhelmingly
been re-dubbed, which is actually part of
why the performances feel so flat and disjointed:
the emotion of the face and lips just doesn’t
quite match the sound that you’re hearing.
Also there’s a different character to the
dialogue that’s recorded in a sound booth
versus the dialogue that’s recorded on set.
It’s subtle, but pervasive.
Now, if you listen to this guy’s lines,
listen lady, I think it's time for you to
go
Hear how they’re kinda mumbly and overlapping
with a lot of room noise and echoes?
I think it's time for you to go
I wouldn’t be surprised to find out that
most of the on set sound was like this, which
is why there’s so much dubbing like this
What does this have to do with my father?
Many people wanted those connections.
People like Bison.
The leader of Shadaloo
Moving on with the plot, Chun Li gets trapped
and captured.
Bison kills her dad in front of her.
She escapes, but takes a grazing shot in a
market, and manages to slip away once a riot
starts.
Gen shows up because he’s not dead, just
a dick, uses magic powers to heal her bullet
wound in seconds, and she finally figures
out how to make a fireball.
Returning to the dock she threatens this guy
again, there's a big fight at the docks, Gen
fights Balrog, they figure out that the White
Rose is Bison's daughter, Chun Li knocks Bison
off the roof with a fireball, kills him in
front of his daughter, buries her dad, plants
some sequel bait, credits roll.
Did you even notice the two supporting characters
that I cut from the plot?
These two?
The interpol agent and the Thai detective?
Nope?
Guess we didn't need them.
His name's Bison I’ve tracked him through
eleven major cities on four continents and
never come close, not once.
They actually take up a substantial chunk
of the screen time, they’re a couple of
cops in pursuit of Bison and his Shadalaoo
organization, but mostly they just sit slightly
off to the side of the action or show up after
everything is over.
They’re pretty much just here for padding
and innuendo.
We should be more aggressive
Looks like you got that down
Well, unlike you, I don't lose my man
Alright, [cracking noise] let's start with
the whole "abandoning your past life" storyline.
The first major flaw in this is that no one
tries to stop her.
Her mother just died, she's clearly in a deeply
vulnerable place in her life, and not one
of these people, friends, or extended family
tries to intervene when she quits her job
and packs up her house.
this isn't indicative of a plot hole, it's
indicative of a fundamental lack of drama
or conflict.
And this all ties in to another issue: she
doesn't actually abandon everything.
She doesn't get up and walk away from it all,
taking only some bare essentials and living
with the poorest of society.
Oh, sure, she sleeps in an alley and skips
out on showering, but at the end of the movie
she's moving right back into her multimillion
dollar Hong Kong mansion.
Living on the streets for a couple weeks was
probably instructive, but she was basically
a poverty tourist.
If she ever got tired of living in a slum
there was always a mansion waiting back in
Hong Kong.
She sacrificed nothing.
This ties directly into the character arc:
Chun Li doesn't really learn anything or change.
At the start of the film she's a confident,
spunky, kindhearted person.
As the film progresses she dabbles in poverty
tourism, kills three men in cold blood without
remorse, and returns to her life of wealth
as a spunky, kindhearted, slightly more confident
person.
Now, that's not an irredeemable problem.
Lots of good movies have main characters who
don't learn or change all that much.
But it IS a problem when your movie opens
with the main character pondering how they
turned into the person they are!
Sometimes I wonder how I got to be the way
I am.
The writers have explicitly set up a transformation
story.
I used to be a little girl who wanted to be
a piano player, now I'm a cold hearted killer
who murders people for the greater good.
I used to be a selfish, upper class snob,
but I learned the value of hard work, community,
and sacrifice.
These are the kinds of stories that we are,
very literally, being told to expect.
Any transformation contrast is deeply compromised
by the early scenes of the film, when her
father is kidnapped.
Now, the problem is not the existence of these
scenes, but their proportional length within
the film.
We're shown that she's been exposed to this
criminal world since she was a little girl
and we only spend the briefest time with her
as a civilian.
This is a really good example of how movies
need to function emotionally and not just
literally.
We can look at the opening of the film and
extrapolate that logically everything between
her father being kidnapped and her success
as an adult was more or less normal but we
don’t feel the respective weight of these
things
Because it's such a tiny part of the opening
her time as a concert pianist feels more like
a brief interlude in a life of violence, a
hobby that she took up to pass the time waiting
for revenge, rather than the normal world
that she's pulled out of, and what little
we see of her in that stage of her life is
basically the same person we see at the end
of the film.
The only thing that changes is the number
of living parents and felony murders.
Next up is the whole thing where Bison transfers
his goodness into a little baby.
I have a couple problems with this scene.
First, and least important, is that the intensity
and violence of the scene is considerably
out of place given the tone and treatment
of violence throughout the rest of the film.
It's an extremely jarring kick-the-dog scene
that's meant to show the audience just how
evil the bad guy is, but I think it becomes
less effective because it's so relatively
extreme.
It's such a sharp break from almost everything
else that it pulls you out to a place where
it stops being the actions of a character
and becomes the decision of some filmmakers.
You’re not thinking about the moment and
its place in the emotional tapestry of the
movie, you’re thinking about why the people
who made this made it the way they did.
The only other scene that comes close is where
Bison is using Cantana’s body as a punching
bag, while everything else is sanitized, bloodless,
fantasy violence.
Beyond that is the implications of this scene
on the metaphysical world of the film.
So, first, things that happen in movies don’t
need to be true.
Like, characters can believe something without
that thing being diegetically factual.
It's one thing for this myth to exist, for
Gen to tell Chun Li this mystical rumour that
he heard, but it's effectively confirmed later
in the film that his daughter is, in fact,
the vessel holding all the goodness of his
soul.
That means that in the world of Street Fighter
good and bad are tangible products that can
be transferred from one person to another.
While the implications on free will and morality
are staggering, most importantly it does nothing
to actually improve the story at all.
It makes Bison less comprehensible.
It doesn’t make his goals any clearer.
We still have no idea what he's up to, what
he's doing on a day to day basis, and what
his end goal is.
It actually makes it worse.
By offloading the explanation onto supernatural
evil the screenwriters fall into the trap
where the villain’s actions are tautologically
justified by them being the villain.
It’s fine for melodrama, Raul Julia understood
that
The day Bison graced your village was the
most important day of your life.
But for me?
It was Tuesday.
But Legend of Chun Li is trying to take itself
seriously.
There's one thing I learned in the slums:
when people are hungry there's nothing they
won't do.
Everyone has a price.
There's a plot in here about buying up waterfront
property for redevelopment, but they're extorting
the city board into making the sale which
makes no sense.
Was the board zoning the area as a slum for
purely altruistic reasons?
It's like the writers couldn't decide if Bison
should be using black magic, private military,
shady business practices, or a Chinatown style
shakedown, so they tried to squeeze them all
in.
It's hard to care about any of them since
the stakes are so vague.
The people who live in the slum get kicked
out, then vanish never to be seen or mentioned
again, not that we ever really connected with
them in the first place.
The big showdown at the end with Interpol,
Bison, and Chun Li doesn't even have anything
to do with the whole slum buyout anyway, and
the plot line is never resolved.
The only reason anyone cares about the White
Rose shipment is because they think it might
be a weapon, even though Bison’s whole plan
is pretty much just capitalism.
To top it all off, the changes to the source
material actively make the story worse.
In her original incarnations Chun Li is alternately
an undercover cop or an Interpol agent.
Changing her from a cop to a concert pianist
does nothing to raise the stakes or make the
character more relatable.
In fact it makes the story hard to tell because
you now have to justify all kinds of crazy
crap that's super easy to hand wave if she
works for interpol.
Why is she in Thailand?
Why does she know martial arts?
Why does she have combat training and not
freak out the first time someone pulls a gun
on her?
Why does she care about the legal front of
a criminal organization?
all of this action nonsense is just explained
in one line if she works for Interpol.
The character conflict comes baked in: when
she confronts Bison does she stick with her
training and let the courts bring him to justice,
or does she extract revenge and kill him herself?
When she meets Gen does she stick with Interpol
with its superior resources, but strict rules
and expectations, or become a vigilante and
join the Order of the Web?
Instead we're asked to believe that a concert
pianist who learned kung fu as a kid is going
to be willing to throw herself at a well armed
international criminal organization and not
wind up as Jane Doe floating down the river.
So, they wanted to legitimize the video game
adaptation and they screwed it up with an
awful script.
Every single problem with this movie comes
back to the script.
The characters frequently make decisions based
on information they don't have because the
script needs to get them somewhere, the villains
are an indistinct mass made of every bad guy
trope possible, resulting in an antagonist
that's too confusing to take seriously, and
entire chunks of the film are flat out useless
to the story.
the funny thing is that they failed so hard
that even when talking about video game movies,
a sub-genre that is peppered with examples
that plumb the depths of shoddy, hilarious,
and hilariously shoddy filmmaking, that they
made something most notable for how forgettable
it is.
It does all make the movie somewhat unique.
You're not a schoolgirl anymore.
Really in all the agonizing over when video
game movies are going to finally be good we
miss that they already peaked with Super Mario
Bros. in 1993.
Okay, look, how many Marios are there between
the two of ya?
There's three: there's Mario Mario and Luigi
Mario
Mike.
Mike!
Help these Marios around the side.